Well, there's so much knowledge out there, so much information,
so many ways to get better
and we make, we make so many mistakes.
We're the,
we're the product of our mistakes and oftentimes the lesson is sitting there
right in front of our face. It's there to be learned,
but we miss it or we don't pay attention to it or we think we know better
until it punches in the face.
And the most important thing to learn is that we have so much to learn.
We all do.
And we can learn from school and from people and from experience and we learn
from life.
But you have to process the information,
you have to absorb it, you have to accept it,
you have to open your mind and you've got to free your mind so that you can
learn.
Yeah.
And make real progress
in as far as regrets and things.
I wish I would've done differently. Of course,
hindsight,
hindsight is 2020 and looking back of course,
who wouldn't want to take another go at something and improve on the first try
by doing it again and then why not do it again?
And again and again.
And why not just do it over and over again until you have it perfect.
But the fact is you don't get that chance.
You get one shot,
one shot at this gig right here. Life,
one life. That's all you've got
and regret in and of itself,
okay?
It's worthless. It does nothing for you. In fact,
the only valuable thing and regret is the lesson you learned,
okay?
The knowledge that you gained,
But walking around filled with regret gets you nothing.
So learn and move on.
Don't let regret beats you down. Don't be a slave to regret.
No. Let it teach you.
Let it make you better.
Let the fear of regret fueled you to take action today.
Now,
okay.
To take action now to become a better person.
Not filled with regret,
but filled with knowledge,
filled with knowledge and strength and power and filled with
light.